92 year old raisa is blind in firm and
terrified
she sits crying on her bed in this
makeshift shelter
shrapnel from a shell ripped through her
leg while she sat at home in the eastern
ukrainian city of marienka
thank god we're alive they shell every
half an hour shrapnel hits everything we
climbed out of the rubble grabbed what
belongings we could then lifted mum out
we found a wheelbarrow and put her in it
and pushed her to the road where a
volunteer rescued us
in a nearby village people wait at a
food distribution point
many have either fled or been rescued
from the shelling in marienka
a volunteer from a church group hands
out plastic bags filled with a few
essentials
ludmila shows us what's inside
we live off canned food and what we can
grow we have no money because we can't
work we can't work anymore this is how
we survive
further towards marienka as the sound of
shelling echoes across the fields
signs of the fighting begin to appear
houses badly damaged and abandoned a
school destroyed
we drive further and into marienka
there's the sound of artillery fire and
occasional small arms fire
russian forces are close
we've been hearing what sounds like
mortar fire
in the center of the city what we do
know is that russian forces control
positions
just a few hundred meters in that
direction on the other side of the river
another shell there
now we also know
that the russians made gains here in
marienko at the early stages of the war
the ukrainian army have since said that
they have now pushed them back
we move back out of town and see black
smoke rising
olenna helps her wounded mother into a
taxi to take her to hospital
it's doubtful raisa will ever see her
home
again
john stratford al jazeera marienka
eastern ukraine